[Music]
here in this video we will discuss a bit
on the designs and the life cycle of the
endos swarmer super species that was
seen in Monarch the legacy of monsters
and also talk about why they might set
the stage for the appearance of
Godzilla's ban his Ultimate Enemy here
in the monsterverse D Roya so we have
quite a few theories to throw at you
here let's get to
it the endos swarmer species discovered
in kazakistan in 1959 these creatures
were found initially as eggs in an
abandoned nuclear power plant where they
even as eggs were feeding on the
radiation in that place slowly growing
and maturing and eventually hatching out
in response to disturbances caused by
Kiko leaw and
Randa there they pursued the cars and
were able to get a hold of Kiko dragging
her into an abys supposedly killing her
when they stumble upon these mysterious
eggs Kiko initially identified them as a
new type of Muto and then later
Entertainment Weekly was the first to
unveil the title endos swarmer a name
that was stuck and gained recognition
director Matt shackman Two Rotten
Tomatoes refer to the creatures as
milliped creatures and then later as the
series unfolded The mature specimen was
called an
ended the endos swarmers as their name
suggest are a swarm species working in
unison even moments after hatching out
they bear a resemblance to arthropods
like millipedes or centipedes featuring
compact armored bodies with a
distinctive single row of sharp spikes
running along their bags and also
elongated legs their dark gray
coloration is uated by striking orange
highlights notably these creatures lack
visible eyes but spot lengthy antenna on
their heads in their infancy they
measure around 2 ft or 60 cm while the
adults exhibit a formidable size
as large as two fully grown elephants
easily over 12 M or 40 ft long and they
are then called the
edes these endres in their mature stage
maintain the chanous armor and multiple
limbs of their Laval forms but they
undergo a considerable size increase
these creatures now have significantly
larger sture featuring four massive hn
mandibles extending from their quadruple
JW mouths adored with circular rows of
razor sharp teeth adding to their
formidable appearance they have long t
like appendages protruding from their Ms
the undersides of the enderes
intermittently emit a deep orange glow
just like their Laval forms creating
birds of vibrant colors at irregular
intervals now let's take a look at their
Origins and their life cycle Kiko
theorized that these creatures were
attracted to surface from their
underground habitat due to the
radioactive energy given off by the
nuclear power plant in kazakistan and
with our added knowledge of the movies
we can infer that they are a hollow
Earth Titan species that came out of a
portal located underneath the facility
which was evident in the episode 8 where
the adult speciman appeared and nearly
killed Kate rander so these species have
three life stages three stages in their
life cycle first as an egg that glows
with an orange Hue with the radiation
that they feed on then as juvenile laral
endos swarmers which are insectoid and
then they mold and shed their skins like
certain arthropods to come out as small
adult specimens which then continue to
grow to the size of the mature
ended now the big question arises are
they a premutated form of the one and
only
Destroyer well to start with the kaju
that caused the death of Godzilla in the
1995 h movie originally started out as a
microf form which grew and became a
crawl form which was sort of like
arthropod or which looks like a troby
now these two like the endos swarmers
are swarm species and work together in
unison acting as a singular organism
they then later grow into the aggregate
form and the flying form ending in the
ultimate Destroyer form but this was all
due to the oxygen destroyer and the
micro oxygen which caused them to mutate
the moners if they are wise can twist
the endos swarmers into an origin story
for their own version of destoya a Kaiju
of high demand by fans to appear in the
monsterverse movies to fight against
Titan goira the endites could be the
equivalent of a juvenile or a smaller
type of aggregate form of destoya of
course they can have their own creative
ways of explaining the origins but the
basic layout has been set in 2019s king
of the monsters where Godzilla and gdar
fought off the coast of Mexico in
2019 they were both hit by a new radical
weapon called the oxygen Destroyer this
weapon as of the Jay movie was in fact
the Genesis of the destrooy creature
most of us could adapt this story and
explain that this explosion in the ocean
was in a close vicinity of a hollow
Earth portal that Godzilla used to
intercept Monster Zero they could say
that the Endo pedes or the endos
swarmers followed the Gman to the spot
but were exposed to the radiation or the
action of the micro oxygen from the OD
weapon this would then mutate them to a
more rapidly evolving organism and embod
of the weapon that nearly killed the
Gman in kotm this could be where
Destroyer finally enters the
monsterverse and fights Godzilla in a
future movie after gxk the new Empire
and that's about
it now if you like this video then check
this other one as well and do check out
our Channel as we might have things from
the monsterverse and other monster
movies that you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care
fam